and i do remember thinking try to do it
without me
guys i'd rock and then i remember tuning
in to season three which i wasn't in
uh at the time and they had a character
called faith
that eliza deski was doing and that was
freaking awesome
and i remember thinking oh my god they
don't need me at all well they did
i don't know i uh think that it was a
character that the writers enjoyed
exploring
you guys got along real well you and
joss no i was terrified of jaws really
absolutely i've never met him but he i
thought you know i thought he was just
such a nice guy gentle man right yeah
but the thing the thing is is that um
uh i was imperiling the theme of buffy
which is
that buffy is actually the same theme as
hamlet which is how do you get
through adolescence how do you see the
world is screwed up and not give up how
do you take
arms against the sea of troubles how do
you how do you make a positive
difference in the world
and um vampires and buffy
are just metaphors for all of all of the
challenges that you face in that period
um and so uh you know joss felt the
vampires should be ugly
they should be very quickly overcome and
they were not supposed
to be sexy he he said i don't like that
anne rice crap
and he got talked into one romantic
interest
vampire that was angel it wasn't his
idea uh
and he that was the only one that was
the exception
and then i came along and i wasn't
designed to be a romantic character but
then the audience
reacted that way to it and i remember he
backed me up against a wall one day and
he was just like
i don't care how popular you are kid
you're dead you hear me you're dead dead
and i and i i was just like uh you know
it's your football man like
okay you know wait was he was he kidding
around no hell no
he was angry with you he was angry at
the situation i think